hi in this video we would have a quick
overview of cell cycle and the cell
division process let's talk about the
cell cycle first we know cell cycle is
actually divided into several phases
like g1 s g2 and the mitotic phase now
each of this phase has different time of
occurrence for example g1 is the longest
whereas mitotic phase is the shortest
now 90 percent of the cell cycle time is
devoted for the interphase so have you
ever wondered why interphase is sold all
and what really takes place during this
long time of interphase
now the rest 10% time is devoted
together for prophase metaphase anaphase
and telophase and among that anaphase
and metaphase lasts for a few seconds so
in this video we will try to understand
how this time distribution is maintained
regulated and why this mitotic phase
takes so less time whereas interphase
take a lot of time so let's talk about
the g1 phase at the first so the g1
phase is the first part of the interface
and the g1 phase the cell received
signal from the outside the signal could
be a growth factor at this particular
phase cell talks to its inner
environment and try to determine that
the environment is feasible for further
cell division or not imagine a situation
were that the environment is not so much
feasible and in the environment not much
growth factor is present then the cell
won't take a risky decision to do a
division because division requires a
hell lot of energy a lot of protein
synthesis and a regulated process so
cell would stop and go in question quiz
ins at that particular time let's say
there is enough amount of growth factor
in g1 phase what cell would do is
try to divide right now there is a
particular time point in the g1 phase in
the late g1 phase known as a restriction
points once the cell crossed the
restriction point it is committed to
division it has to divide now at this
end of the g1 phase the cells also
duplicates its mitochondria
it also duplicates its centrioles which
is important for a cell division purpose
now let's talk about the S phase or the
synthesis phase as the name suggests you
can clearly understand S phase is the
time where the replication of the
genetic material takes place now s phase
is pretty long as well because lot of
enzymes are required for replicating the
genomic material right and those
proteins which are important for
replicating the genomic material was
previously synthesized in the g1 phase
such that they can be readily used in
the S phase after S phase there is a g2
phase now in this gap 2 phase few
important thing happened the gap 2 phase
the cell transcribes and translate all
the enzyme that are necessary for the
preparation to divide and for diffusion
there are a whole lot of proteins
necessary so all of these translation
and transcription all this preparatory
phase is basically the g2 phase after it
crosses the g2 phase the cell won't have
enough time to do all these synthesis
stuff because at that point of time its
sole goal is to monitor the chromosome
segregation process everything is
packaged it just need to divide that's
why mitotic phase is so short in mitotic
phase there are like several
subdivisions like prophase metaphase
anaphase and telophase in this video we
would look at at least in a brief
fashion that what are the main events of
this phase so first it is prophase from
the g2 boundary 2 pro
Fay's few important changes happens in
the cell first and foremost the
centrosomes which are duplicated at the
end of g1 phase now try to go into the
two opposite poles they would be also
visible at the microscope chromosomes D
condensed and chromosomes are now
visible using normal light microscope
now you can see inside the nuclear
lamina there is something called lemon
now lemon works like a structural
support for the whole nuclear membrane
and lemon get phosphorylated by several
proteins several cycling's which we
would be talking in other videos and
this would allow breaking down of laman
and dissociation of the laminate
structure as a result there is a
collapse of the nuclear membrane at the
same time to spindle of two mitotic
spindle apparatus with the centrosomes
it would try to mobilize to the opposite
pole of the cell and they kind of get
recruited there and wait for the
metaphase to occur now at prometaphase
stage the spindles from the micro tube
the microtubule organizing Center is
moving towards the center of the cell in
search of chromosomes the microtubule
gets attached to the chromosome and its
kinetic or and try to align the
chromosome at to the center of the cell
which is known as the made of a jig
plate after that this process of
positioning them into the metaphysic
plate is pretty difficult and highly
regulated so soon after the chromosomes
are arranged in the mirror metaphysic
plate few quality control steps take
place so first of all there are tension
sensing molecules which make sure that
the chromosome is the chromosome is
experiencing equal amount of tension
from both the sides and that would
ensure the equal segregation of the
chromosomes now there is a classical
problem in the process of separating the
two chromatids because it is an
enveloped inside a cohesin ring cohesion
ensures the stability of the chromosome
now somehow you have to break this
cohesin ring such that you can pull
these chromosomes apart from the two two
to the two sides right and the cohesion
is basically broken during the end of
the metaphase to anaphase and the way it
is broken is by enzyme called separate
separate is stimulated by maturation
promoting factor or mitosis promoting
factor MPF about this we would learn in
a different video but let's say there is
an let's say there is a problem in the
cohesin disassembly or there is a
problem in the microtubule association
with the chromosome then there is an
error signal and then on their cell
cycle would stop it won't progress
further and there are mechanisms which
ensures that no error happen in this
process and it is important because if
this kind of error takes place during
the division there could be in equal
segregation of the chromosomes into two
daughter cells right so there are
certain substances like maturation
promotin factor and many other cycling's
make sure this doesn't happen but this
MPF also has to be degraded at certain
point imperial is degraded at the
surface pro anaphase at the start of the
NF s with the help of anaphase promoting
complex now at the NF is the chromosomes
are equally segregated towards the pool
of the cells after that till of it
starts in telophase the prevalent
activity of the de phosphorylase enzymes
get rid of phosphorylation from the
nuclear pores get rid of correlation
from lamina such that they can
reorganize and on that scaffold nuclear
membrane can reorganize as well so as a
result nuclear membrane be organized and
two distinct nucleus has started to form
following this telophase there is a
Carioca in the the final cytokinesis
division is there where a cleavage
furrow is formed and after a certain
point of time two cells are separated
this whole process looks pretty
complicated and highly regulated right
if it doesn't happen in a proper fashion
you would end up by getting multiple
nucleus in one cell which is called as
in Cydia and many other pathological
situation can occur in order to make
sure that this process of cell division
goes smoothly and all the errors can be
rectified there are specific cell the
cell cycle checkpoint mechanisms which
are mainly regulated by psy queen and
cdk complexes now cyclin-cdk complexes
are turned on in specific time windows
and they have their job in that
restricted time windows after that they
get degraded if you want to learn more
about cyclin-cdk the link is given at
the end of this video now we start from
a single cell and from there we divide
if identified and grow to a whole
complex organism and how amazing is this
right how orchestrated this whole
process is if there is a problem in this
division and there is an abnormal
division such that it would lead to
uncontrolled cell division it might lead
to cancer and cancer is basically a
pathological situation when there is
uncontrolled cell division the mechanism
that leads to cell division and cell
proliferation goes wrong in cancer if
you want to learn more about cancer the
link is given at the end of this video
so that's pretty much summarized this
whole overview of cell cycle and cell
division in next videos we would learn
about the phases of the cell division in
a lot more details so stay tuned thank
you
you